I'd now like to introduce you to Robert
Oxley professor at the department of
economics at the University of Calgary
and Allen and I'm he's the vice
president of community building and
investment with the United Way welcome
so I'd like to thank everyone for coming
I don't know about you guys but this is
the first time I've had to stand up in a
second so if anybody wants to stand up
go ahead it just it's totally worth
doing so I'm going to talk a little bit
about some of my work and different from
Alex and Kath I'm an economist by
training and so I'm going to focus a
little bit more on the economics of
things I do experiments and so I'll talk
a little bit about some of my
experiments there's a I grew up in San
Francisco and if you grow up in the
States there's this classic book you
read called invisible man and it's not
about a guy who disappears it's by Ralph
Ellison and it's kind of one of the
classic books of American literature and
it really is this devastating take on
growing up african-american in the
states in the 19 you know I think 19 in
the post-world War two ERA and this book
is what's so telling about this book is
there's this the main character has all
these opportunities that come his way
and none of them come to fruition every
you know I mean and he's discriminated
against there's a whole there's a whole
you know it's not his fault in some ways
I mean there's a whole it's worth it's
worth the read but it's this really
devastating story of when this guy's you
know using the language you've been
talking about here when this guy's
social or personal identity doesn't mesh
with all these opportunities that come
his way
and we can see this type of effect happy
you know this type of loss or this type
of identity conflict if you will with
resources in a bunch of marginalized or
disadvantaged groups across Alberta
across Canada across the world so what I
want to do is talk a little bit sorry I
gotta grab my glass I have these new
glasses they're giving me a headache
good hey but anyways part of this
thinking about the relationship between
identity and resources and opportunities
is falls under the rubric of ideas of
social inclusion or social exclusion or
social cohesion and there was this big
study in Europe where they really looked
I mean their primary focus well the
largest focus was on immigrant groups
coming to Europe particularly from Asia
and Africa and they were looking at what
it is that stops these people from
integrating or from taking advantage of
resources that are available and they
identify three characteristics that fit
with social exclusion one of them is
relativity that individuals are either
included or excluded relative to another
group the other is agency that the
inclusion comes to an individual through
acts of others and dynamics that there's
this you know individuals are included
because of a current state but also
perceptions about what the future holds
for them if you think about what Alex
and Kath have been talking about these
are all aspects of social identity and
in some sense the real shame in this big
European study is that they looked at
all this stuff and they tried to
manipulate resources and programs to try
to address each of these three things
without identifying the fundamental
theme that runs through all of them
which is that you feel excluded or
included based on the social groups in
which you interact and what you perceive
those groups to be doing in the future
and how you perceive things to be
changed which is
fundamentally a question of how you
perceive yourself and what your identity
is so basically what they did is they
kind of focused on providing people
access to rights and resources removing
obstacles of social institutions and
kind of economic institutions you know
implementing different
anti-discrimination laws implementing
different immigration programs
fast-tracking work permits and things
like that without fundamentally
addressing the social institution which
all these people were interacting and so
this whole approach kind of makes you
think about this the aspects of social
identity so how do you define your place
within a society how do you consider
your role within the larger community
and what norms of behaviors or
expectations that you do you identify
with and which end up motivate your
behavior so I want to put forth a kind
of an economic framework for thinking
about these ideas which relies on the
role of social identities or of identity
in general and then I want to look at
two experiments that we've done out of
the University of Calgary so so everyone
here taking an economics course okay
even if you haven't what's the one thing
you remember about academic economics
there we go supply and demand right
fifty years after any course that's the
one thing that everyone remembers it's
an L and an X and somehow it manifests
itself in like the economy working and
unemployment and interest rates
everything can be explained by that
graph that's the kind of traditional
economic approach right and what that
caught what that approach is based on
fundamentally is that there are these
goods the stuff the widgets the iphones
the cars and all that stuff we buy and
that they have these characteristics
right the iphone sorry different from
the blackberry which is different from
some other phone I don't know I just
have an iPhone and they provide us
utility and that's why we buy them and
that's where we get supply and demand
Amartya Sen who was a famous economist
came up with the idea really kind of
redefining that and thinking about what
really happens is that these commodities
provide k
abilities they provide opportunities for
us to do things and that's what gives us
utility or welfare so a car provides you
a means for transportation a Jag may be
nicer than a VW no of 78 VW bus to some
people but it provides a means for
transportation and that capability is
what's important education provides a
capability for skill acquisition and if
you acquire skills then you can do
better in the job market so it's the
capability that matters similarly and
relevant to one of the things I'm going
to talk about banks and financial
institutions you know you can think
about those as providing commodity
services whatever they provide a
capability to transfer money to borrow
to save to plan for the future things
like that now if we expand that a little
bit thinking about kind of the work
that's been done in behavioral economics
which is kind of incorporating some
ideas from psychology we have you know
people have endowments or there are
policies out there in which we interact
they provide us with certain commodities
those commodities provide capabilities
and then there's this interaction but
you know this is kind of what behavioral
economist talk about there's this
interaction between what our cognitions
are what we think about the capabilities
and you know what our expectations might
be for those capabilities interactions
and then those actions provide utility
and welfare good so far if I lost
anybody all right I'm trying to keep us
get us back on schedule so what's the
role of social identity social identity
fundamentally affects the way we think
about those capabilities they fund you
know social identity fundamentally
thinks the you know affects the way we
think about the resources that are
available to us so if I identify with a
group that disparages post-secondary
education then my identity stops me from
realizing the capabilities are
associated with post-secondary education
if I belong to a group of you know if I
socially identify with a group that is
unbanked it doesn't have bank accounts
doesn't use the traditional financial
systems that we're all
using and are using payday lenders or
pawn shops or things like that then
providing low interest loans for housing
and things like that you know our
identity stops us from realizing the
capabilities associated with that and
that's fundamentally if you think about
you know kind of a neo-classical whether
that doesn't help but if you kind of
think about the academic economic stuff
the supply and demand story that we all
kind of know that's really where that
fails because we're not a capturing this
idea of how we perceive all these
capabilities that come available to us
so so if you look at what the type of
approach is that policies we think about
the promote inclusion or you know
mitigate exclusion we think about
providing job opportunities we think
about providing health services we think
about providing low income housing we
think about providing social protection
to marginalize or disadvantaged group we
think about providing education and you
know you know skill upgrading and all
sorts of training opportunities so the
emphasis here has been fundamentally on
thinking about the supply side right
that's going to be the upward sloping
curve in that little supply and demand
picture which is you know encouraging
people to join the labor market to move
into labor market to get better skills
things like that to improve their health
through services and the demand side by
removing employer perceived obstacles
right so I may have you know I may be
discriminating against a marginalized
group I can put in legal things to stop
that I can put in you know education to
try to prevent that which is affecting
the demand side that's going to be the
other that's going to be the downward
sloping 14 so what I want to do right so
but what's neglected here is the aspect
of how people access these research and
how people consider these resources so
in the five minutes I got left let me
talk about two studies we've done and
think about them
little bit from the social identity
standpoint so we did some studies with
the autism societies in Calgary and
Edmonton we also did some studies with a
group called my organization called
momentum in Calgary which does match
savings and financial literacy programs
let me talk about the autism one let me
just dump all this up there there we go
so what we did is we did a survey study
of members of the Calgary autism and
Edmonton autism societies and what we
were looking for was how they accessed
resources and their perceptions of
symptom severity in their children I of
a my son has autism is quite severe
autism and so that's kind of where my
interest comes from and the one thing
when you go through and you look at you
know as we asked them all sorts of
questions the one thing you know and one
of those things was what are their
social networks and what other social
groups look like and what groups do they
belong to and how do they identify with
every parent with autism identifies with
every other parent with autism and you
go oh great that's you know that's the
first step in getting people to access
resources the problem is they don't and
the devastating thing is that there are
a lot I mean Alberta you know if you
have a child with autism of all the gin
joints in all the world Albert is the
place to be it has the highest level of
resources it has the most kind of
advanced social programs for children
with autism it's incredible
unfortunately those parents are they
don't take advantage of any of them and
what you look is if you if the parents
identify with the organization's they
have a greater awareness of available
resources they have greater information
you know and I mean their service
resources so I'm talking there about
therapeutic type of resources or
Community Engagement resources they have
greater information regarding the
financial resources that are available
the children with two parents of
children with disabilities and they have
greater information regarding the
community events that go out there which
include not only things of you know like
the community swim for children with
autism
and other disabilities but also parent
support networks and groups like that
the interesting thing is that those
groups as they identify with the autism
associations they also report lower
levels of family stress for any given
level of symptom severity which you know
having some having a child autism it's a
strata mean being a parent's a tough job
being a parent with a not you know is a
stressful job and you know it just it's
just a different level of stress they're
equally stressful but it's stressful and
what you see is that this you know
having this knowledge or identification
with the Community Association
significantly reduces that independent
of any type of independent of symptom
severity and when we think about the the
effect of this I'm going to go over time
I mean when I'm talking about the
financial resources here I mean people
who don't identify with their autism
Association our signal you know they're
much less likely to know about thing
about our DSPs so registered disability
savings plans which only have a take-up
of about twelve percent they don't know
you know they're much less likely to
know about the disability tax credit
which is about 10 grand that has a
take-up of less than fifty percent so
these are massive chunks of financial
resources that are available that people
don't take advantage of in the autism
community we did a secondary study with
this and what we looked at is can we
motivate identification with the autism
community and or with the autism
associations and this is kind of like
setting up a bit of a buddy system with
somebody who's in the organization for
parents with newly diagnosed children or
parents who are just not involved with
the organization and what we find is
that one year later once we've got them
to kind of identify with the
organization they report lower levels of
stress they applaud they are much more
aware of the financial and service
resources and they have a much higher
degree of in-home therapy which
is really by family members which is
really continuing the therapy program
you have with children with autism
continuing that when the therapist
leaves the room so the families are much
more likely to keep that type of therapy
program going which is really
fundamental to trying to provide these
children with independent living skills
and other sexual skills let me talk
briefly in the second I have left about
our study with momentum so momentum
provides match savings programs and
financial literacy programs for people
living in poverty specifically looking
at families and the idea is that these
resources through these match savings
programs which vary from two to one to
five to one depending on the program
you're in are used for skill upgrading
starting a business and in some cases
purchasing a home and these are families
that are living just the kind of the
qualifying thing here's either family
are living that fifty percent or less
than the low income cutoff so these are
significant you know people living in
significant poverty our survey evidence
there and we've done a bit of
experimenting that the financial
literacy programs you know they kind of
do what you expect them to do they
result in lower levels of subjective
discounting so people think about the
future much more they are much better at
thinking of you know planning for future
and thinking about what budgeting and
things like that involves the successful
participants are much more likely to
have a greater sense of control but the
big thing here is that for these
programs to be effective what we've
noticed is that the most successful
participants have a fundamental change
in their identity they identify
themselves differently you know as a
part of a different group and part of a
group that plans for the future you know
I don't know about you know you guys but
when I was 20 years old and new
everything I didn't think about the
future I didn't think you know I mean my
primary financial thing was I had a
checking account and i had a pawn shop
near my house and that's how you know
that
was my you know that was my financial
planning through my late teens and mid
20s um you know what do you do but I
still knew everything the but that but
that that change from moving from
unbanked to banked to thinking about
retirement savings to thinking about
home purchase requires a fundamental
change in identity and that's the thing
we've noticed with momentum is that it
would financial literacy is great people
can think about balancing a checkbook
that can know how a savings account work
they know how to newly works they retain
that information much more they we
observe much more behavioral change if
their identity changes and those become
things that are salient in their new
identity those are become norms that are
relevant to them let me just end with a
quick a couple closing comments but the
short of the whole thing is that when we
think about new policies and program up
taking things like that without you know
we have to take into account the
identity that people enter these things
with if we don't we can provide all
sorts of resource to marginalize
disadvantaged groups advantage groups
whatever but without they're not going
to take advantage of those unless we can
provide a means for their identity to
internalize the different norms of
behavior that come with those resources
and I think that would be the thing to
consider as we consider program design
as we consider policy development that
thinking about what it is that you know
how do we get people to internalize
these norms how do we get people to
identify with the fundamental changes
we're trying to facilitate facilitate
through resource allocation or through
policy design thanks a lot
last but not least Thank You professor
roxb it's pleasure for me to be here I'm
going to respond to Professor Oak's Keys
presentation but it's been enlightening
in some respects as well I mean I have a
close friend he was at University
roommate who moved to Sydney which is
not too far from where you are and he
developed manic depression and so I have
conversations with him from time to time
the old fashioned way by phone and he
tells me all the time about these groups
he's involved and of course he's working
with a doctor he's work he's off he
sometimes has to pay visits the hospital
for periods of time but it just occurred
to me that these are likely being
prescribed as part of his ability to
cope with his element so very
interesting from that perspective so I
want to share a story about my
nine-year-old daughter and this sort of
keen delight this is a conversation I
had with her probably about a month and
a half ago and as I was preparing for
this I thought whoa in a minute I recall
that discussion she just tell me about
her day of school just usual
conversations and she was telling me
about something that happened on the
playground there was a little girl in
her class that really wanted to play
with a group of girls and she went over
to that group of girls and ask hey can i
join in and they said no I can't believe
already in great for that sort of thing
happens but it does and and so this that
apparently happened to be four so my
daughter being the kind of kid she is
went and invited this girl to come join
her group and the girl you know said no
and and so now my daughter is kind of
freaked out thinking well how could that
be I have extended an invitation for her
to come be part of our group and this
girl said no so we had a bit of a
conversation about that as well maybe
maybe she's scared maybe her experience
has not been positive in the past maybe
she's afraid to go join your group
because of fear could be anyway so and
while the world and its challenges may
be a little more complex than the
playground at a great for school their
story is still I think quite
illustrative and to that little girl who
was excluded there's no doubt that that
moment in previous moments had an impact
on her identity and has shaped her way
of thinking so what she may not have the
capability for instance to it trapped
with a healthy group without some
persistence on behalf of others to make
that happen so structurally in the
social service sector for those who are
most vulnerable we exclude we exclude
people we don't intentionally do it but
we do and there could be a variety of
circumstances behind why we exclude why
we don't build on the capabilities of
individuals who may be able to connect
in and access services and so there are
variety of reasons there's the
structural there's things like
transportation you know child care
housing and we've talked about all of
them already we've heard about them all
there's stigma isolation racism
discrimination language barriers you
name it there's a whole rate and well
there are some who against all odds
still managed to associate with a
healthy group still managed to connect
in with the appropriate program or
service that will provide for them what
they need many don't and they may be
just like that little girl they may have
had experiences over time that have
compromised their capability to
intercept with healthy healthy groups
that will forge a positive social
identity that will give them the
capability to change the circumstances
the better and of course they give up
they may seek isolation because
ultimately that's less painful so by
them making that decision of course we
as society we judge you know your when
PowerPoint slide showing the homeless
man you know we a society judge all the
time we might label them lazy we create
stories about them about how they got
there but why they're there currently
and also as you mentioned how we also
infer their potential
the potential to be something different
in the future and you know it has a
sector we all try very hard we tried to
do the right thing we don't want any of
this to happen we want to engage
everyone who needs support and provide
that support we want to create lasting
meaningful change for people you know
there's a growing intolerance and this
is a good thing for managing issues and
a desire to start trying to think
creatively about changing things
permanently for people now I recall a
conversation back when franca was part
of our group here in Edmonton with our
funded partners and I remember the
conversation about it was a number of
excellent organization sitting around
the table talking about how there's a
lot of good stuff happening in the
community we're all doing great work but
the stats whatever stat you want to
point to whether it's poverty
homelessness mental health whatever high
school completion rates you name it the
stats aren't changing we're not moving
the needle so how can we work
differently how can we come out things
differently I mean there are those who
have some capability and who just need a
nudge and they will have the ability to
benefit from programs and services and
on autism first of all and have the
ability to benefit in to change for the
better and change permanently but for
those most vulnerable how do we move the
needle for them how do we get out some
of those statistics and so 10 years from
now we see significant improvement
that's the question so that was a
question that Franco and others in that
room posed as a group just try to figure
out in terms of our group what's our
role in this what can we do to problem
solve it so that challenged us as an
organization as a united way to try to
figure okay what-what stake can we put
in the sand we generally been about
everybody and everything we ultimately
landed on poverty as a mission for us if
we created a framework around that but
through that process we had a number of
consultations with our partners and we
asked them look you know the sector is
what it is you know it's kind of evolved
to be what it is our city has changed
our reason region has changed if we
could you know Park it all and say okay
the city is what it is now how can we
create a social service infrastructure
that will support people in a meaningful
way where they're at draw it up
differently what would
look like and through the great
conversation essentially three scene
three themes emerged one person centered
services programs need to be
person-centered we need to meet the
person from where they're at and often
the ability to access that individual is
through an existing association or group
some affinity they currently have where
there's trust where there's identity
build there's the ability to leverage
that to be able to create meaningful
lasting change it is challenging as an
individual especially maybe a new
individual to navigate a system services
to be able to find what you need when
you need it and so system navigation was
certainly a theme and the
person-centered approach was a way of
helping with that one door is the right
door and from that point of view with
whatever association or group that is we
can then wrap ourselves around that
individual a system in whatever way is
required no one issue is it works in
isolation it's always a complex mixture
of issues that impact a person's life
and ability to change so a
person-centered was certainly one
another was placed based so we have a
system that currently is very
centralized in most cases but when we
look at the city we have I think over
the last couple of years we had about
60,000 new people move into the region
the Alberta Capital Region that's a lot
of people through migration immigration
through some population growth but
significant numbers and they're all
moving downtown where the services are
they're moving out into the outlying
areas they're moving to where housing is
affordable of course that is one of the
areas that is a barrier and so what can
we as a sector do to ensure we are there
where they are at that is where their
associations are hopefully that's where
their connections could be in their
neighborhoods the structural barriers
around transportation can be mitigated
by having supports and services in place
in those areas now of course the cost of
doing that are astronomical and the
bricks and mortar of organizations and
programs and services don't need to be
in every neighborhood in every every
part of the city but at the same time
the capability of the
sector to be able to meet people where
they're at and intersect with their
groups and their associations in their
neighborhoods who's seen as pivotal and
then the third piece was shared
leadership it is not just the purview of
the social service sector to be able to
create lasting change that would
ultimately move the needle on social
issues or various departments or
ministries within various levels of
government it's not just that part of
our society that needs to care it's the
private sector it's individuals all over
we do not change anything unless
everyone is certainly rowing in the same
direction so we have seen and make no
mistake there is there are a lot of
great examples too many to go into in
the time that I have left which I
probably don't have any time on there
are many extraordinary examples out
there of this happening of initiatives
were company's social service
organizations various levels of
government foundations individuals are
all participating collectively around
trying to address an issue maybe in a
specific initiative but it's happening
we just need to need it to happen more
we need to scale up there needs to be
more of it and that's already been said
and I would certainly echo that
sentiment now just you know it's
interesting I have somebody close to me
who struggles with alcoholism and so
I've done a bit of reading on this and I
had I did this the old-fashioned way I
read it and I didn't have access to a
computer or printer so I wrote it out a
quote from this how archaic right but
anyway it was a blog that I was reading
an huffington post by a fellow by the
name of Johann Hari and and he's he was
traveling the world trying to find some
sort of solution to the addictions
because people in his life were also
struggling with addictions of all sorts
and so when I when I read it I just sort
of struck me that it kind of describes a
little bit about what we're talking
about here today so I'll just going to
read from this the writer George bo bo
has called this the age of loneliness we
have created human societies where it is
easier for people to become cut off from
all human connections than ever before
Bruce Alexander and he's an author and a
researcher told me that for too long we
have talked exclusively about end of
recovery from addiction or insert
whatever issue you would like we need to
talk about societal recovery how we all
recover together from the sickness of
isolation that is sinking us like a
thick fog loving an addict is really
hard when i looked at the addicts i love
it is always tempting to follow the
tough love advice doled out by reality
shows like intervention tell the attic
to shape up and cut them off their
messages that an addict who can't stop
should be shunned but in fact i have
learned i will only deepen that approach
will only deepen their addiction and you
may lose them all together I came home
determined to tie the attics in my life
closer to me than ever to let them know
I love them unconditionally whether they
stop or whether they can't think it's
important message now back to my
daughter me persistent one the very next
day after being shunned I told know how
dare they how dare she she went up to
this little girl once again the very
next day and invited her to be part of
her group and she said yes so she's very
happy about that it turns out that
social complex social issues in grade
four can be solved in one day so we can
learn something it may take us a little
longer but certainly we need to persist
and we need to try to continue to
leverage the capabilities the group's
the associations that others are
currently engaged with and be able to
bring services and supports to them in
that fashion thank
you